When we talk about a recession, we're usually
talking about the state of the American economy
in total in some kind of broader sense and
we're not there yet.
I mean today we, we do not appear to be in
a recession.
There are concerning signs that we've talked
about, but it would not be accurate or at
least defensible broadly to say that the country
is in a recession right now.
But there are parts of the country that are
in a recession and at this point that is really
impossible to deny.
And the recession that exists already in parts
of the country are very highly connected to
Donald Trump's trade war with China.
The also are connected to things like automation,
uh, and some other things that are bigger
than Trump.
But Donald Trump's trade policy is certainly
precipitating this.
So let's first start with what is the definition
of a recession?
A recession is a period of temporary economic
decline during which trade and industrial
activity are reduced, generally identified
by a fall in GDP in two successive quarters.
You need only look at places like Wisconsin
and Pennsylvania and a number of other states,
specifically in the industries of agriculture
and manufacturing to realize that we have
a regionalized, agricultural and manufacturing
recession right now.
It's happening right now.
This is not maybe at some point in the future.
Okay.
You have farms and farmers themselves experiencing
drastically reduced trade and industrial activity
to borrow the terminology from the definition
of recession because of a fall in their production
as a result of the trade war.
You then have the sequential effects of related
drops in industrial activity at companies
that make farm equipment.
Companies like Kune and John Deere Kune recently
furloughed hundreds of employees for two weeks
because they have slowed down production as
a result of farmers being hit by the trade
war.
The trade war by shrinking farm trade is shrinking.
The economic activity of companies like Kune
and others, so they are forced to cut production.
And when you zoom out a little bit and you
look at the index of manufacturing activity,
you see a contraction last month for the first
time in three years.
When you look at manufacturing jobs, the number
of new manufacturing jobs has dropped from
170,000 added at this time last year to just
44,000 barely enough to keep up with population
growth.
This is stagnation in 22 states.
The number of people working in factories
has fallen in the first seven months of 2019
according to the economic innovation group.
So are we in a recession right now as a country?
We cannot say that at this point in time.
At some point soon, we may be able to say
it is agriculture and manufacturing and a
recession in a lot of the country.
Yes it is.
It is a regionalized recession that's happening
right now and you can actually go further.
There are places where the 2008 recession
never really ended.
The economically ravaged places in the Midwest
and elsewhere that simply never fully recovered
and are now already getting hit again.
Now, in fairness, you know, I, one of the
things that I try to be consistent about is
whether it's a democrat or a Republican in
the White House, I assign blame only to the
extent that it is warranted and when there
are things that are bigger than who's in the
Oval Office, I tell you part of what's going
on is bigger than Trump.
It's bigger than Trump's policy.
There was a, a something called creative destruction.
This is a mechanism in the business cycle.
This was, uh, the, the term creative destruction
I believe comes from marks, but it meant something
else.
Joseph Schumpeter, an Austrian economists
know left winger by any means.
Uh, sort of took the term and described it
as an inherent feature of capitalist economies,
which is the constant revolutionizing of the
structure of the economy by changing the dynamics
of it and there is some degree of that.
The United States is experiencing that there's
a move away from manufacturing in general.
There's a move towards tech and information
and other sectors.
Parts of what we're seeing right now in manufacturing
could be certainly influenced by creative
destruction by automation.
That is not Donald Trump's unique fault either,
but the bottom falling out this quickly specifically
because of Trump policy at a faster rate than
it would otherwise and nothing is being done.
Big picture other than throwing some subsidies
at some farmers that is Trump.
Trump's trade war according to an estimate
from Moody's has killed 300,000 to jobs in
total.
So this is not good.
This is of course, potentially the, the, the,
the early indicator of things to come, not
in a recession right now broadly, but we don't
have to hypothesize about the future because
we have a regionalized manufacturing and agricultural
recession happening right now.
Go and look at the really good interviews
with farmers and manufacturing companies,
farm equipment, manufacturing companies that
media outlets like NPR have done.
It's really good work.
It's happening right now, and to pretend it
isn't is a disservice to so many workers that
are already being affected by what's taking
place.
We will be talking more about this on our
Instagram page at David Pakman show, which
I encourage you to follow.
You can also follow me while you were there
at David dot pack.
We will take,
okay, very quick rate and be back with a lot
more right after this